Blamed for terrorist atrocities on at least three continents,...
...Osama bin Laden was the target of perhaps the largest US manhunt in history.
But bin Laden's image as the world's most - wanted terrorist...
...stands in sharp contrast to his peaceful and comfortable upbringing.
Born March 10th, 1957,...
...he was one of more than 50 children of a wealthy Saudi construction magnate...
...who died when Osama bin Laden was a teenager.
Raised in the opulence of Saudi Arabia's upper - class,...
...rubbing shoulders with members of the ruling royal family,...
...bin Laden went on to pursue an engineering degree...
...and seemed headed for work in the family business.
But his life forever changed when, in 1979, the former Soviet Union invaded Afghanistan.
Bin Laden, like many Muslims, left home to join the fight against the Soviets.
But in the mid - 1980s, bin Laden decided to use his share of his family's wealth...
...to form his own militia force, which later became known as "al-Qaida", Arabic for "The Base."
Another major turning point in his life came in 1990...
...when Iraq invaded the oil - rich Persian Gulf state of Kuwait,...
...prompting Saudi Arabia to invite US troops to deploy within its territory.
Bin Laden saw the arrival of non - Muslims...
...on what he considered holy land as an affront to Islam.
He protested strongly against the move,...
...resulting in his expulsion from Saudi Arabia in 1991.
Stopping bin Laden became the top priority for the United States...
...following the New York and Washington attacks in 2001,...
...which claimed more than 3,000 lives.
When the Taliban refused to surrender the al-Qaida leader to US authorities,...
...the United States went to war,...
...ousting the Taliban from Afghanistan in December 2001 and sending Osama bin Laden into hiding.
In his years at large, bin Laden released a series of audio tapes condemning the United States,...
...causing great frustration for Washington,...
...a frustration that has now ended.